hey David given that there's been so
much talk about voting in part because
of the midterm election a few days ago I
want to ask you a question what is worse
voting ignorant or not voting at all
because you always talk about the
importance of voting but do we really
want people who don't know anything
going out to the polls so this is mean
it's the framing is not unfair but it's
sort of a deceptive framing no one is
advocating that I've seen going out and
voting by shooting darts so to speak
randomly picking candidates to vote for
that I would argue really doesn't help
anybody but the case I would make is
that even an uninformed voter turnout of
90% would force politicians to pay more
attention to what people want
even if they don't always know what they
want or they want things that don't make
sense then when you have fifty percent
voter turnout which quite frankly we
already have filled with ignorant people
and malignantly misinformed people
anyway in other words the idea that the
options are to go from we either stay at
50 percent voter turnout and everybody's
informed or we go to 90 percent voter
turnout but everybody is uninformed all
of a sudden we already have a huge
percentage of the voting public
completely uninformed about the issues
and the candidates you you really barely
need to do any research to be better
informed than random choice doesn't mean
I'll agree with you but if we have
representative democracy it should be
representative of as many votes as
possible so is the idea to convince
people to vote uninformed like is that
the idea behind just vote everybody vote
of course not but if voting is something
everyone or almost everyone does
by sheer osmosis colloquially speaking
not literal osmosis the level to which
people are informed on average is going
to go up okay and I've actually had
periods where I started thinking through
ideas like well what about voting tests
you should at least have some level of
knowledge in order to vote and obviously
that stuff would would be illegal it
would never fly and I think it would
also kind of be antithetical to the
spirit of democracy that the the framers
of the Constitution envisioned but now I
realize that absent anything else absent
a more or less informed voting public
like putting all of that stuff aside the
more votes that are cast the the more
people that vote the better off we are
overall and so the I think it's a false
question to even say do we really want
more people voting if they're not
informed and and additionally I would I
would further that case by saying the
following if everybody voted it's
extraordinarily difficult for me to
imagine that you would have a less
informed population because right now
because only half the country votes by
sheer chance of course depends where you
are a whole bunch of the people you
encounter every day are non voters
meaning they are often less engaged in
the political process and less
knowledgeable if we had 90 percent voter
turnout even if initially you had a lot
of people voting uninformed the fact
that more people are participating will
increase the likelihood that you're
interacting with people every day who
are part of the political process that
will lead to conversation and that will
inevitably lead to people who are more
engaged aware and informed it doesn't
mean we will agree with the conclusions
they come to but that's sort of a second
layer argument and the most important
thing is if we want our elected
representatives to be accountable to us
the more of us that vote the more
accountable they would conceivably have
to be at least as a founding premise and
then of course you have to figure out
will anyone actually hold them
accountable but I think that it is a
false choice to say is it better for
more people to vote if everybody's
voting uninformed it's not the way it
would work it's not actually what would
happen in practice if you disagree with
me on this one I do want to hear from
you